hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to perhaps
a love you saw the trailer for the movie
sausage party no of course you didn't
you just saw the title the catchphrases
and starring the YouTube comments like
everyone else I remember a ton of people
sending me links declaring it the new
food fight but much to the surprise of
yeah every single person who ever lived
it was actually getting good reviews no
not just good great word-of-mouth starts
spreading as well and soon the movie
became a hint
why because apparently the movie has
clever satire thought-provoking
commentary and a scenario that helps
make its point this movie this got me
thinking recently why start I taught you
well
that this isn't the first time this has
happened there's been several movies and
shows they've been popping up over the
past several years that seem like
mindless nonsense but either slowly or
quickly reveal themselves to be smarter
than they look with many of them doing
well more and more have been popping up
out of the woodwork so this makes the
question is weird the new brilliant with
so much media that seems like junk food
for the brain is there some junk food
that's secretly sneaking in some healthy
stuff I start thinking about movies and
shows that were doing a lot of this and
quite frankly a lot of them seem to be
animated popular shows like Adventure
Time or Steven universe have been
praised for years for their in-depth
look at identity and how it relates to
social norms whether it be family
friendship or how viewing oneself can
affect others as well as you but if you
were to put that on the summary of the
show very few kids would probably watch
it I'll probably not even have any
adults there for effect your time is
about a teenage boy who wears fluffy
white ears and a zany dog who can change
it to anything and their wacky
shenanigans in the magical land of boo
but since it's a magical land you can do
whatever you want so maybe someone
magically make smaller versions of
everyone that can be put under your
control
thus we can explore how much a seemingly
loving person can give or take when in
complete power or maybe a magical crown
that takes away your memory can serve as
a heartbreaking allegory for Alzheimer's
and the empathetic tragedy that people
suffer from
these are things that spiraled out of a
show that started like this listen to
Jake Finn he only wants what's best for
Steven universe is the same way it
starts off with a little boy who has a
gem in his belly trying to show these
three alien women how life on Earth
works and the first episode focuses on
an ice cream tree called cookie cat well
what's in a while stopping an alien
invasion and singing a song doesn't
sound that mentally complex but again as
the show continues we discover the gems
can transform you both physically and
mentally and combine with other people
the themes they explore here are an
existentialist wet dream themes about
intimacy gender identification puberty
sex childhood becoming adulthood the
list goes on again
all beginning with an episode focusing
on him wanting a cookie cat ice cream
all seems kind of insane it doesn't
always have to be symbolic though
sometimes they can just be
straightforward shows like Avatar My
Little Pony are very direct with what
they're trying to teach avatar takes
place in a fantasy world where people
have Captain Planet powers and want to
stop an evil bad guy from taking over
the world yeah sounds pretty standard in
fact almost boring but on top of having
a great sense of humor and creative
visuals the show teaches kids and
arguably adults about Eastern
philosophies religion medicine and even
martial arts moves all the poses shown
are based on real styles of martial arts
they even hired martial arts masters for
models in the case of My Little Pony a
show that started off as a remake of
what many people consider forced excuse
to sell toys and that's when the people
who liked it had transformed into
practically an educational show about
emotions and social interactions the
story takes place in a land of ponies
and one is sent to study the benefits of
friendship yeah sounds like Care Bears
greeting card fighter right well in this
show they actually do analyze it
seriously looking at the benefits of
kindness the varying levels of it and
when to use each variation it's easy
just to say be nice and that's it but
the show actually looks at the different
challenges that comes with it it isn't
just a blanket turn it's explored and
analyzed so much so that the majority of
the fan base are grown men not girls
this is a show that was doing its job so
well that it had on a fan base that they
weren't even aiming for originally and
now it turns out to be most of them and
all this comes from a show that just
wanted to sell some toys in the 80s who
the hell could have seen this coming
kids films nowadays are the same way
Kung Fu Panda has a Jack Black Annamayya
comedy teaching kids about dealing with
suffering how to turn it into something
progressive the lego movie is really a
connection to a son's relationship with
his father and good Lord we could talk
about the Pixar movies forever giving us
cute and silly ideas that sneak in
emotional and psychological issues
without kids even realizing it but this
idea of working commentary into nonsense
isn't just for kids on top of examples
like sausage party Bojack horseman might
be the greatest TV show in years and on
the surface you swear I was making that
up it's about a horse who had a cheesy
sitcom in the 80s yeah that's right a
horse half the people are animals on the
show there's no reason for it the whole
series focuses on the impact that the
show had on him particularly depression
and dozens of addictions and how it also
impacts the people around him the show
starts off almost mockingly silly
relying on shock value jokes and classic
little problems they are blown out of
proportion but as we get more
comfortable with the characters there
are more trouble sides our show and
often times instead of punchlines or
given harsh harsh realities yeah harsh
realities in a show about a talking
horse it's like finding out mr. ed was
bipolar what's so shocking about this
show is not only does it do the dramatic
side well but it does it better than any
show I've seen on television the comedy
is drawn surreal and clever allowing us
to enjoy these people so when it really
comes time to talk about the inhumane
side all of them are capable of that's
really tough to get through in a good
way it is disturbing it does take you
out of your comfort zone and it does it
in a totally bizarre and intriguing way
maybe the constant reminder that said in
the false world of Hollywood is what
helps us see past the gimmick of talking
animals maybe because we're so aware
Hollywood is an illusion but forget the
people behind it or real feeling
creatures helps us identify with such a
strange and hostile environment
it takes you to places you didn't think
you would go to are afraid to go to and
then come out having confronted
something you never thought you would
have confronted all from Bojack one
hundred percent on Rotten Tomatoes
horsemen where did this all come from
that these childish and dumb ideas can
lead to deep and complex issues it's
hard to say for sure
I guess feels like South Park kind of
paved the way looking like the cheapest
lowest brow humor event over time
surprisingly turned into one of the
great commentators because there were so
low expectations there was a freedom to
do whatever they wanted and not only did
the creators know how to get people's
attention but they knew how to say
something funny and interesting while
they had your attention but L you could
go back further and point to the
Simpsons when they first came out it was
dismissed as crude shock humor yeah The
Simpsons were seen as shock humor years
later though we still quote their
ingenious comedy and yet we still have
no idea why they're yellow or how their
hair somehow becomes their skin we all
just kind of accept something that silly
TV wise you could even point to The
Twilight Zone
a spooky show of scary twist that often
has a dark satire on the human condition
I guess even comics can be thrown into
that batman/superman and a ton of the
Marvel stories are all being held now as
the new Greek mythology's with a lot of
challenging ideas both psychologically
and culturally it's even been kind of a
big thing in literature lore the rings
in Narnia have a lot of religious
connections for stories about wizards
and magic animal farm is obviously
telling the rise of Stalin and communism
even though it's just about a bunch of
barnyard animals even Wizard of Oz is
technically an allegory on the populist
movement yeah no joke there's actually a
whole other layer that many of us miss
so I guess the real question is if it
can be done so well when is it done
poorly I've gotten a lot of hate for
saying this but for me it's films like
science district 9 and The Matrix films
the reason being if you took the very
obvious allegory out the stories don't
make any sense there's a ton of plot
holes focusing issues and character
choices that don't add up they focus so
hard on what they're trying to say what
their symbolism that they're forgetting
to give you characters you like choices
you understand and then
narrative that makes sense this is why
the examples I listed before do work
they want you to like the characters
first they want you to feel like you can
live in these worlds they want to make
you laugh they want you to have fun that
way when they slowly work their way to
the more profound scenes you're
emotionally there with them you give a
crap you're invested because they were
given time to sink in
I don't care what happens to neo he says
dolls a plank of wood if I'll get
invested in the world or the characters
first I'm not gonna care what you're
trying to say with them maybe that's why
so many of these brilliant ideas are
animated because for so many of us
that's the first thing we see we grow up
with cartoons they hold a certain place
in our hearts so they'll immediately get
an emotional reaction when something
happens to them
some people can't get into animation and
all I see it as kids stuff and that's a
shame because a lot of kid stuff is
acting more adult recently even the
Looney Tunes in Rocky and Bullwinkle
snuck in a lot of adult jokes and they
did it because they knew they had a
medium where they could and with all the
technology that's available to us now we
are seeing worlds that can exist much
faster and much better looking than we
ever imagined maybe that's why so many
of these weird but brilliant stories are
happening right now we certainly had a
couple here and there in the past but
now it seems like there's more than ever
and many of them are still going they
know now that they can do it and that
people will watch and continue to watch
their minds are open to being
entertained but also question they want
to see a horse get drunk and act like an
ass but they also want them to wonder if
there's any hope for itself I don't know
this is just a trend or these kind of
stories will keep going but one thing is
for sure they got our attention now and
they're doing a pretty good job keeping
I'm gonna stash your credit Guy remember
so you don't have to coming next weakest
the third animated Titanic movie yes it
exists you've asked for it for years and
I'm finally going to give it but you can
see it now under vessels ad free early
access just three dollars a month to see
tons of people's videos early as well as
a bunch of other extra features check it
out and get the early scoop
[Music]
you